habanero peppers okay Chipotle puree I
think I could do this one there's
something about this one wait
[Music]
it could be on Insanity bro it sounds
like the worst circuit let's hit circuit
everyone Sean why would we go beyond
Insanity on a Tuesday morning at 11 48
of afternoon at 12 53 or whatever it is
I know we're just going that's it you
know I'm just I'm on your schedule here
all right so whoa going right in
it hasn't kicked her in yet maybe it
won't
I think this is where it started yeah
that is where you turn the corner though
yeah it gets hot right there different
yeah it does a different vibe all
together yeah unusual there the first
thing it hits from here is your eyeball
I might ask you to spoon me in a second
whatever you need whatever you need to
get through it oh wow that comes in
strong yeah they all have their pitfalls
and it grows and it grows and it grows
out
wow
wow
that's hot oh my mm-hmm
totally different level
[ __ ] I'm literally cried no I know it's
fine
what's the point of this right now
I'm like like gushing tears but
not me
I just have a little spit up a little
spit up
yeah it's getting hot now
what's matter with Jesus he's all right
well man with you
I just wanted it not hot
[Music]
my precious
come on team never give up wow get the
milk get more milk ready so why did you
drink the milk what's the difference
between the milk and oh God damn it's
hot and then just be careful you know
sometimes when people drink too much
milk that becomes like a worse problem
than the hot sauce you know yeah maybe I
think of all the things this is the most
effective
oh
it's good to see you suffer misery loves
company it really it does help
all right I'm sure yeah
this is your [ __ ] job my heart's
racing yeah it's uh Transcendent this
sauce the kids don't need to do anything
they're related you need the bomb and
you will find your spirit
this is a part of the [ __ ] hot one
Spiritual Awakening and I'm here for the
experience like I'm here for it okay hot
ones indeed
whoo and I've never eaten anything this
spicy I never will again why would you
do this to me
I want to talk to you anymore
nobody's ever whooped your ass after all
these chicken wings
stop the camera I'm gonna go over there
and whoop your ass
[Music]
the bone